ganz ehrlich wollen wir auch über
folgendes Thema reden und viele Menschen
fürchten derzeit wie es für sie
wirtschaftliche weitergeht die
Wirtschaft die geätzberg ab und für Sie
Frau Hermann gibt es da einen Grund das
hängt mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine
zusammen wie soll es weitergehen ihr
Thema gerade eben nicht mit dem Krieg
der wird jetzt immer als Ausrede benutzt
das ist der Anlass sozusagen um alle
Sachen die früher nicht angepackt worden
sind da reinzupacken und das ganze damit
zu beenden und wissen es nicht gewesen
und wieder so eine rühre mich nicht und
Hut verloren das ist aber nicht richtig
der Westen wird schon seit na ja
spätestens seit der Liebenden Brothers
Krise in den USA 2008 in seiner
Bedeutung verringert wir erleben dass
die Chinesen das war jetzt gerade
gestern erst deutlich machen dass sie
der Meinung sind dass die Amerikaner den
Krieg in der Ukraine begonnen haben das
heißt auch dass er mit den Amerikanern
darüber reden muss den zu beenden die
Europäer sind darauf angewiesen dass der
Krieg beendet wird es kann nicht so
weitergehen aus meiner Sicht kaum ist
man bereit ein paar Panzer zu schicken
dann werden auch gleich noch die
Flugzeuge eingefordert ich habe noch
nicht gehört dass man den Krieg mit mehr
Waffen beendet man beendet den entweder
mit Verhandlungen oder erschleicht sich
irgendwann aus Erschöpfung aus das hilft
aber alles nicht weiter weil Europa
ökonomisch jetzt auf Amerika fokussiert
wird die USA wollen das auch sie ziehen
auch Industrie an aus Europa genauso wie
sie aus Taiwan die IT-Branche abziehen
und damit entkernen sie natürlich auch
diese Staaten und wir sind davon
abhängig bei dem hohen
sozialstaatsniveau dass wir in
Deutschland haben dass wir unsere
Exportorientierung aufrecht erhalten
wenn die Welt aber sich jetzt gegen
Amerika verbündet und das sieht so aus
also nicht nur die brix-staaten jetzt
haben die Brasilianer und auch die
Argentina gesagt wir haben eine
gemeinsame Währung in Zukunft den Flur
und wir sind einfach nicht mehr abhängig
die Saudi sagen okay wir können das Ölen
das Gas auch nicht mit Dollar verkaufen
wir können das auch mit Johann und
anderen Währungen verkaufen damit ist
der Petro Dollar in Gefahr damit ist die
Leitwährung des Dollars in Gefahr und
wenn wir selber uns jetzt immer
ökonomisch nur noch da dran hängen
obwohl Deutschland in die ganze Welt
exportiert hat und nicht nur nach Amer
Amerika dann haben wir ein massives
Problem lassen sie uns da ganz konkret
mal dran bleiben sie sagen also
deutschland als Exportnation hat quasi
keine Zukunft mehr wenn das so weiter
läuft wie es jetzt läuft du hast
jedenfalls dramatischer als es im Moment
aussieht im Moment klingt das alles noch
super nach büllerbü und so weiter die
Steuern sind auch höher weil die
Inflation das natürlich treibt das ist
kein wahrer wert das sind nur
inflationsgetriebene Zahl die höher
klingen als vorher wir haben aber jetzt
große Entscheidungen vielen Branchen
Siedle ich mich woanders an oder bleibe
ich in Deutschland oder bleibe ich in
Europa wir können es auch größer ziehen
und diese langfrist Entscheidungen gehen
immer mehr zu Ungunsten Deutschlands aus
wir werden über Jahre hinweg keine
günstige zuverlässige Energieversorgung
haben das ist ja nun alten wie bekannt
ja das Pfeifen 2 Zentner schwerer
Spatzen von den Dächern dann haben wir
die Situation dass wir noch nicht mal
wissen ob wir auch das LNG von den
Amerikanern kriegen werden wie es
avisiert worden ist die haben selber
genug Probleme und die werden noch
zunehmen wenn der Dollar als leitwertung
relativiert wird dann platzt natürlich
in den USA auch die Naht
weil die davon sich mal ein riesen Dispo
bauen konnten weltweit sozusagen in dem
alle die Leitwährung gekauft haben und
dann waren die immer an Bord wenn das
nicht mehr stattfindet wenn das eine
regional Währung wird dann ist die
Nummer durch und das Währungspaar Dollar
und Euro ist ganz dicht miteinander
verknüpft deswegen macht die EZB jetzt
vielleicht auch in etwas mutigeren
Schritt bei der Zinserhöhung aber die
Lage ist wirklich ziemlich verratzt
lassen sie uns ja noch mal bei
Deutschland bleiben sie arbeiten ja auch
mit vielen Mittelständlern zusammen was
berichten die ihnen wo wollen die hin
mit welchen Gedanken spielen also die
haben ja jetzt schon seit Jahren
Probleme die wir ausgemacht sowieso
haben durch die demografische
Entwicklung z.B fehlt es ein Fachkräften
es wird ein jungen Leuten die man
ausbilden kann zu Fachkräften das haben
wir selber verursacht dass unser Ding
dann gibt es jetzt neuerdings die Frage
mit der Energieversorgung die war bis
Sache mal 2020 nicht so wie Olymp jetzt
ist sie virulent und wenn sie dann zu
Bedingungen und Kosten produzieren
müssen wo das Produkt teurer ist als auf
dem Weltmarkt gehandelt wird und stellen
Sie die Produktion ein oder sie
verlassen das Land ich habe
Mittelständler die Patrioten sind die
ihre Regionen lieben ihre Leute muss
leben die da verwurzelt sind und Familie
zu Hause sind die sagen ich muss meine
Produktion wahrscheinlich auch verlegen
es ist dann eben einfach so hin das ist
ja verschieden USA zieht ja an die geben
ja Versprechungen ab was man da alles an
steuerlichen Erleichterungen bekommt
wenn man die Produktion rüberverlegt wie
viel billiger ist es denn da was kostet
der Strom ist deutlich günstiger aber
das sind auch steuerliche
Erleichterungen die machen das Ihnen
direkt oder Abu Dhabi bietet 80%
Zuschuss für die Ansiedlung einer Firma
wenn es eine Produktion und Branche ist
die sie wollen dann kann man auch nach
Ungarn gehen wenn man das möchte nicht
steuern günstiger also es gibt
verschiedene Möglichkeiten aber
außerhalb des Euroraums eben ne so und
das muss jetzt das erwägen ganz viele
und die müssen sich das durch den Kopf
gehen lassen und aus meiner Sicht ist
das im Moment noch nicht so auffällig
weil durch diese demografische
Entwicklung und die fehlenden Fachkräfte
in Deutschland auch ja Leute wenn sie
entlassen werden die werden gleich
wieder aufgesaugt deswegen sieht man den
Arbeitslosenzahlen nicht ne aber
insgesamt nicht die Produktion ab und
noch hat Europa was zu sagen als
Industrie reg in der Welt mit ungefähr
ein Fünftel nicht ganz so 18 Prozent der
Produktion weltweit wir sind noch wer
aber das kann jetzt ganz schnell weiter
Schrumpf und weiter runtergehen und dann
sind wir niemand mehr dann schließen
sich die prickstaaten zusammen dann
schließen sich noch die anderen Länder
alle haben sie Deutschland blutet aus ja
ich glaube Deutschland blutet aus und
das wird schwieriger werden
made in Germany das ist eigentlich ein
ja Begriff der klingt nach Erfolg der
klingt nach Qualität sie sind teilweise
in den USA auch aufgewachsen sind dort
noch wahnsinnig oft was bedeutet made in
Germany dort wie blicken die USA auf uns
ich bin noch nicht ganz so pessimistisch
für die Hand ich glaube wir Deutschen
sind zwar eher mal Zürich aber das hat
auch seine Vorteile ja eine unglaublich
Wissen großer Forschungsstandort wir
haben fantastisches Universitätssystem
das am wenigsten auf der Welt die
Universitäten sind immer noch gratis was
in den USA nicht der Fall ist also ich
mache wieder etwas weniger Sorgen ich
glaube da sind sehr viele Fehler gemacht
worden in den letzten 20 Jahren gerade
in die ist die Abhängigkeit von Putins
Gas betrifft die Abhängigkeit von ihnen
als Medikamenten Hersteller da ist
natürlich ihre Spiel ausgelagert worden
in ihrem Rahmen dieser Art die
Globalisierung so toll und plötzlich
haben wir keine Medikamente mehr
plötzlich ist die Energiewende hätte
merkt man jetzt hätte vor 20 Jahren mal
richtig befreit werden müssen da sind
Fehler gemacht worden aber ich glaube
wir sind ja nicht im Kopf gefallen wir
reagieren ja relativ schnell wir sind
jetzt bei über 40% regenerative Energien
da bewegt sich ja was es werden auch die
Medikamenten Produktionsstätten
wahrscheinlich wieder zurück bewegt
werden Richtung Europa also ich bin da
ich möchte sie nicht widersprechen
Ausbildungsniveau das haben wenig Länder
auf der Welt wir sind offensichtlich ein
wahnsinnig attraktives Einwanderungsland
das heißt ich glaube auch dieser
Fachkräftemangel wird aufgefangen werden
durch Einwanderung dass man die USA
betreiben ist er sportlich dass wenn die
Jobs fehlen dann werden sie halt
reingeholt die Mannes sehr gezielt
wieder aus drei Kinder die auch das
werden wir auch anfangen soll was
brauchen wir gerade brauchen wir
Pflegepersonal brauchen wir sie dann
wird man genauso die
Einwanderungspolitik bestimmen das wir
lernen halt wir haben eine langsame
Lerngruppe aber die Stehtisch müssen
auch Sina Friedensverhandlungen wie ist
da beispielsweise die Stimmung in den
USA sehr gespalten die Republikaner sind
ja eher skeptisch was sie unterstützende
Ukraine betrifft die Demokraten sind
sehr dafür ich als Deutsche für mich da
schwer weil ich bin 15 Jahre nach Ende
des Zweiten Weltkriegs geboren ich weiß
es Hitler nicht mit Verhandlung gestoppt
wurde sondern mit Waffen ich glaube Herr
Putin ist ein Massenmörder ich halte von
der größten Verbrecher der derzeit und
ich glaube den kann man im Moment nicht
mit Behandlung stoppen sondern nur mit
Waffen das ist meine ganz persönliche
Meinung das ist auch die Meinung in
ihrer Partei und jetzt wurden die
Kampfpanzer beschlossen jetzt gibt es
den Ruf nach Kampfjets wie stehen Sie
dazu noch den kampfschutz das glaube ich
nicht weil das heißt ja dann auch wir
müssten ja wenn wir nur noch Ukraine uns
auch halten dann bringen uns die
eigentlich nicht viel überfliegen kann
man nicht das das funktioniert ja auch
einfach nicht wir können aber jetzt
nicht zurück also das heißt im da wird
ja eigentlich unsere Freiheit so ein
bisschen mit verteidigt das ist einfach
so wir haben jetzt zögerlich jetzt nach
vielen Monaten die die Panzer geliefert
und jetzt müssen wir ja versuchen das
gerne gesagt glaube ich auch der steht
mit dem Rücken an der Wand und jetzt
werden wir sehen wie wir da rauskommen
aber auch ihre Meinung finde ich gut
weil man muss auch verhandeln das einen
muss man tun aber das andere bitte nicht
lassen was ich aber glaube ist wirklich
dass wir in den nächsten zwei drei
Jahren hier wirklich eine riesiges
Problem kriegen mit den Unternehmen wenn
sie sich mit Unternehmern unterhalten
die gehen einfach weg das ist jetzt
gerade eine Situation bei uns äh bei uns
im Landkreis liegt Nürnberg und Lüneburg
da machen Edeka Märkte zu weil die aus
der eigenen privat aus dem privaten Geld
zu pumpen müssen weil die Energiekosten
nicht mehr bezahlbar sind obwohl sie die
modernsten Kühlschränke haben und
Gefriertruhen müssten sie für eine Pizza
8 oder 9 € nehmen
wie es weitergeht das Problem
frühzeitig einfach europäisch gedacht
haben auch im Energiebereich ja jeder
macht sein eigenes Ding wir steigen aus
ähm
steigt aus ich habe das ja hier vor
Monaten von der Landtagswahl gesagt
jetzt ist Niedersachsen raus nach dabei
kommt Niedersachsen rein so dann auch
passiert ja man es wäre überhaupt nicht
schlimm gewesen wenn man vier Jahre
verlängert hätte und neue Brennstäbe
genommen hätte ähm denn wir sind ganz
andere ganz andere Atomkraftwerk als die
in Frankreich und und überall wir wir
300 neue Kohlekraftwerke wenn in China
gebaut gerade und wir wie wir versuchen
die die also gar nicht in ganze sitzen
aber unsere Preise gehen immer höher die
Leute können nicht mehr bezahlen auch
der Arbeitnehmer und der der Rentner der
kann einfach nicht mehr bezahlen und das
ist ein riesen Problem und da wird
keiner folgen wir sind seit Jahren aus
Atomkraft ausgestiegen keiner steigt aus
ersten welche ausgestiegen sind jetzt
wieder drin
einmal ganz kurz beim Krieg bleiben wo
ziehen Sie die Grenze U-Boote Düsenjets
also vor drei Monaten hat man haben
einige gesagt sie hat keine Panzer ja am
Anfang
gedacht das ist jetzt über ein Jahr geht
das muss einfach so sehen funktioniert
nicht wir haben gerade vorhin ausgeführt
USA und China fangen jetzt an sich
gegenüber zu stellen da ist Europa
ungünstige Lage und Europa wird sich
jetzt mit Russland irgendwie arrangieren
müssen weil der Amerikaner jetzt keine
Nerven mehr für diesen regionalkrieg in
Europa und die Chinesen haben das mit
Taiwan das klären die Kommunalwahl in
Taiwan waren so dass man eher eine
china-freundlichere Partei wieder
gewählt hat die alten Kommentaren das
heißt es wird also die Frage aufkommen
ob nicht Taiwan wieder zum Main and
China dazukommt das wird mitunter
kriegerisch beantwortet die Amerikaner
ziehen die IT-Branche raus damit die
schon mal nicht an die Chinesen geht und
in Amerika sich wohlfühlt aber wir
werden unsere Lage hier selber klären
müssen aus indischer chinesischer
arabischer brasilianischer und
eigentlich auch aus US sich die sagen
das noch nicht so deutlich ist das ein
innere europäischer Krieg Putin nimmt
immer nur die Europäer nicht ernst weiß
ich nicht mit rumbekleckert haben bei
den Minsk Abkommen wenn jetzt aber
sozusagen die Europäer selber diese
versuchen zu starten und wir müssen aus
dieser Kriegssituation rauskommen sonst
werden wir zerrieben dann finde ich soll
das allererste wert sein das wäre
wirklich
und die amerikans mit Abstand die
größten Waffenlieferanten ja das hat
doch am Anfang so gezündet aber jetzt
ändert sich gerade das Format ich habe
ja versucht zu deutlich zu machen dass
jetzt sehr deutlich in wenigen Monaten
sich eine Front gebildet hat die sagt
wir haben jetzt die Faxen dicke damit
dass die Amerikaner weltweit immer
bestimmen was wie gespielt wird sie
stellen die Spielregeln auf aber sie
sind die einzigen die sich nicht dran
halten müssen ja leben gerade dass ich
wirklich global Kräfte verschieben und
die die kriegsstaaten sind auf vier
Kontinenten zu Hause die haben über 12
neue Anwärter die alle mitmachen wollen
die china hat USA zurechtgewiesen das
hat so noch nicht gegeben das ist
diplomatisch und umgekehrt ja aber das
ist diplomatisch für mich jetzt doch
interessant die Chinesen sind immer
zurückhalten ihr Formulierungen und das
dann einfach aus dem Außenministerium in
Peking verlautet wird die Amerikaner
sind schuld am Krieg in der Ukraine ist
eine sehr eine Deutlichkeit die China
eigentlich nicht machen ich sage ja nur
was los geht und sagen Sie gerne immer
zu ja ich meine wenn die Chinesen
angefangen das ist natürlich absolut das
ist ein schön
Handcreme an putin ist damit davon
gekommen die ganze Welt der tatenlos
zugeschaut dann ist doch nur die nämlich
die Ukraine gleich mit und jetzt hat die
Welt sich gewehrt also ich glaube egal
was ich in diesen sagen das ist nicht
Diktatur ich habe glaube am felsenfest
daran dass ich Demokratie Demokratie
habe auf lange Sicht eher durchsetzen
als
Diktaturen Fakten auch für den inneren
Frieden in Deutschland ja aber trotzdem
krieg ich mein Brasilien ist das also
kann man wirklich nicht mit Europa
vergleichen argentinien ist ein
entschuldige wirtschaftlich ein
Schrotthaufen schon seit 30 Jahren also
ich habe jetzt nicht die wahnsinniger
Staaten uns alle überrollen werden
ehrlich gesagt naja überhaupt derartige
Probleme also reden so wir können gerne
mal Probleme reden
ganz anders betroffen als wir also alles
klar aber trotzdem die haben innerhalb
der letzten 10 15 Jahre so enorm
zugelegt in ihrer Bedeutung ihre
wirtschaftlichen und das geht in dem
Tempo wahrscheinlich weiter und die
sitzen am längeren Hebel weil sie die
ganzen Rohstoffe haben ganz normal dass
er vorhin gesagt 18 % liegt noch in
Europa oder in der Europäischen Union
was die Produktion Industrie natürlich
wird es weiter zurückgehen wir sehen 500
Millionen Menschen wir sind mittlerweile
8 Milliarden Menschen auf die entwickeln
sich ja alle weiter und das heißt
natürlich werden wir da weiter
zurückfahren es geht aber jetzt glaube
ich mehr darum was sind die Best
Practice die wir von hier in Europa auch
exportieren können damit diese Länder
nicht die gleichen Fehler machen weil
CO2 Belastung haben wir angesprochen die
historisch haben wir seit 150 Jahren
schon Treibhausgase ausgestoßen und das
liegt ja zum größten Teil in Nordamerika
und in der Europäischen Union das heißt
heute die Länder die unter dem
klimawandler am meisten leiden sind die
die am wenigstens in den letzten 150
Jahren ausgestoßen aber der Witz ist an
der Sache dass die alle jetzt ein
bisschen mehr Wohlstand haben wollen für
ihre Bevölkerung damit sie diese vielen
Menschen auch ernähren können und damit
es Ruhe gibt in den Ländern und da
werden die alles verheizen und alles
nutzen was sie kriegen können und was
funktioniert damit eben die Bevölkerung
das Gefühl hat es geht bergauf einmal
lassen Sie uns einmal beim Thema Krieg
bleiben die Grünen haben sich da anfangs
noch schwer getan jetzt aber sind sie
ganz klar auch für Klasse
wie positionieren Sie sich da persönlich
früher ist ist immer links da muss man
in der Friedensbewegung sein ich würde
sie jetzt eigentlich eher links
einordnen wie geht dieser Zwiespalt für
sie innerlich auf jeden Fall ein
Zwiespalt und ich kann nur sagen also
wenn ich jetzt hier in Deutschland
gezwungen werden würde eine Waffe in die
Hand zu nehmen oder ins Gefängnis dann
würde ich gehen und ich würde aus dem
Land fliehen mit meiner Familie weil ich
absolut ich habe den Wehrdienst
abgelehnt und habe gesagt machen
Zivildienst weil ich möchte keine Waffe
ich glaube eine Welt die friedliche ich
bin dabei ganz bei dir Hannes Hitler
wurde auch nur leider musste Millionen
Menschen da sterben und es wurden sehr
viele Waffen produziert um gegen
Deutschland gewinnen zu können das heißt
es gibt manchmal Situationen auch ich
obwohl ich ein paar Pazifist bin wo ich
überzeugt bin dass wir nicht sagen
können ja dann verhandeln wenn man ein
bisschen und dann wird es schon alles
sein ich glaube da ist jetzt Stellung zu
zeigen und den Menschen in der Ukraine
zu helfen und da eben auch zu sagen wie
können wir denn heute die Situation und
die ist katastrophal in der Ukraine den
Menschen zur Seite stehen und das ist
nicht
Angela merschel findet in Zukunft ohne
sie statt ich bin Pazifist ich kann
selber nicht die Waffe in die Hand
nehmen das möchte ich nicht kann ich
nicht aber ich kann mich auch jetzt
nicht dazu bekennen zu sagen ja die
sollten doch mal in Ukrainer einfach
sagen ja der Putin dann ist es halt so
dann sind wir jetzt halt Teil von
Russland das geht ja nicht deswegen kann
ich die Menschen in Ukraine und ich
kenne die persönlich sehr gut verstehen
dass sie ihr Land verteidigen ihre
Freiheit und dass wir da auch zur Seite
stehen wie geht's ihnen da sie sind auch
wirklich haben sie da auch innerlich
etwas mit sich ausgefahren
wunderbares Konzept aber es gibt eben
dann Erscheinung wie ein Adolf Hitler
wie ein Wladimir Putin ich möchte keine
anderen Namen mehr auch für mich dazu
ähm wo glaube ich Pazifismus und
verhandlungsgeschichte nicht sehr viel
weiterführt und deswegen bin ich der
Meinung dass mein Putin tatsächlich
stoppen muss wir haben ihn natürlich
unfassbare Bereich und mächtig gemacht
indem wir Jahrzehnte lang sein billiges
Glas werden ja diese ganzen Russland
Kuschler gerade in der SPD auch in der
CDU und auch in der FDP wir haben diesen
Mann unfassbereich gemacht seine
Kriegskassen vollgespielt mit Milliarden
von Petronas und wundern uns jetzt dass
er doch einen relativ mächtigen
Militärapparat am Start hat also das
haben wir ja ermöglicht diese Macht von
dem Putin und ich fand den von Anfang an
ganz grausam jemand der hat den
Vernichtungskrieg geführt ich habe in
Syrien Flüchtlingslager gedreht auch da
dann Vernichtungskrieg geführt also
jetzt zu tun als wäre das ach Gott jetzt
hatte die Ukraine das heißt alles lange
hervor Ankündigung 18 % der Deutschen
würden sagen sie würden ja eigenes Land
verteidigen hat das gerade angesprochen
wie schwierig der Gedanke ist als paz
ist seiner Waffe zugreifen wie
verständlich aber auch es ist dass sie
Menschen in der Ukraine als über feines
Land eben genau das tun würden sie
selbst zur Waffe greifen also wenn ein
wenn Entbindungsstationen und
Krankenhäuser und Theater und Schulen in
der Ukraine bombardiert werden kann ich
Leute verstehen die sagen ich schreibe
sowas für uns haben sich auch Tausende
von Frauen in der Ukraine nicht ich
verstehe das total wenn sie es auch tun
ja und sie Herr Fellner würden sich
schwer tun ich bleibe aber ich bring das
nicht übers Herz aber trotzdem habe ich
meine Frage was mich jetzt wirklich
verstört und das ist gar nicht aggressiv
gemeint das ist das in einem Atemzug
Adolf Hitler und Putin und vielleicht
noch ein dritter oder so genannt werden
ich habe das immer so verstanden in den
letzten Jahrzehnten als ich dann als
neudeutsche dazu kam dass in Deutschland
eigentlich der Stand der Dinge ist dass
die Nazi Verbrechen nicht vergleichbar
sind und dass man auch Hitler nicht
vergleichen kann jetzt höre ich da so
ist alles irgendwie also ich finde das
schon große Unterschiede zu dem was
unter Hitler passiert ist und zu den
Kriegen die die Amerikaner im Irak das
fand ich auch nicht in Ordnung oder
obwohl es im jammern und habe ich viel
bereits ich habe gesehen was da
angerichtet wird jetzt noch Filme von
Freunden
dass da gab es eine Menge Krieger sag
ich mal und auch der Krieg der Putin
darauf verstauen gebrochen hat ist nicht
gerecht aber ohne erfolgreichlich nicht
legitimierte da brauchen wir uns nicht
streiten das ist immer einig aber in
Syrien und in Georgien und in
Tschetschenien
ich weiß auch dass die Türken z.B auch
in Syrien stehen da redet kein Schwein
drüber entschuldigt sage aber was ist ja
was läuft denn da ab
meiner Meinung nach ist das irgendwie
wohlfeile dass wir alle möglichen Leute
da kritisieren dass sie keine machen und
sie sagen
geändert am Anfang glaube ich wollte
Putin nur mit den USA verhandeln weil
die Europäer nicht ernst genommen hat
inzwischen hat sich die Lage geändert
die Chinesen greifen von hinten
sozusagen mit ein strategisch und
stellen die USA und dann müssen die
Europäer ihre Sachen lösen und ich hätte
gerne eine gemeinsame Initiative von
Deutschland und Frankreich um das zu
beenden mit diesen Krieg und da kann es
sein dass es zu Verhandlungsergebnissen
kommt die uns nicht ideal vorkommen man
hat damals nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
die DDR auch an einen Russen gelassen
und nicht zusammen gelassen als ein Land
oder sowas es gibt mitunter bei
verhandlungenentscheidungen die
schwerwiegend sind aber ich würde diesen
Krieg beenden das wird ins Nirvana für
die Europäer und für die Russen was soll
das wir müssen damit aufhören